[Music]
hallo YouTube chairs lost my friends
this is guns in here welcome to my first
episode of advanced chess and game
tutorials this tutorials will not only
provide ideas and patterns for a
specific endgame positions but overall
it enhance your chests hand game
knowledge and create better winning
chances
and the first diagram I have here it is
white to move and you can clearly see
here that we have the same color bishop
but white has advanced born on the
seventh rank which is just one move away
from the queening right now it is well
protected by this dark square bishop so
my question is as a white how you are
going to create vin from this position
now there's a first golden rule in
endgame that you are not looking at a
specific move rather than it's very
important that you create a varying
plant first and then accordingly execute
your moose so here I want you to pause
this video and find out a wedding plan
where white can able to make this born a
queen and win the game well
congratulations if you find the right
plan that is let's say I move my bishop
to this square and my simple idea is to
reroute this bishop with Bishop to e3
Bishop to e7 Bishop to be it so now
challenging the dark square bishop of
the black and once this bishop move then
I can able to create this passer to the
queening so very good if you achieve
this first step now comes the second
important point once you execute your
plan you need to identify how your
opponent is going to disturb that lon in
other words you need to consider moves
by your opponent which can distract your
plan and a given position the problem
with our plan is black has this more in
the picture that is King to b5 so let's
say white plays the obvious move Bishop
to e3 going to the a7 square well now
comes the whole point that is king to a6
and black is stopping Bishop to e7
in other words stopping the whole white
winning plan so again my question is you
know the plan now you
No now what sort of difficulties black
and create so the third obvious thing
how you can defuse your opponent plan so
kindly pause this video and find out how
you are going to create win from this
position onwards
did you find it let's see now before I
show you the next move it's very
important to understand the position of
this dark square Bishop is a key point
of the whole position so for example
let's say I roll back to the starting
point and here instead of white move if
it's a black to move then it's very
obvious that black has to move this
bishop somewhere and let's say he played
the move Bishop to g3 well now it's a
completely different scenario because
here white can execute his plan very
smoothly for example the first obvious
movies Bishop to h4 challenging the
bishop black cannot take this bishop the
reason is the pawn is queening so black
has to put this bishop somewhere else
let's say Bishop to f4 and now white can
execute his plan that is Bishop to f2
and on the next move white is going to
put his Bishop on a7 an important point
to note over here is this King required
two moves to control the a7 square so a
simple lion can draw like this King to
b5 Bishop to e7 King to a6 attacking the
bishop but now comes the whole point
that is Bishop to b8 attacking the
bishop and it doesn't matter whether the
bishop goes for example fish up to e3
Bishop to g3 and now White has a very
simple plan to execute that is queening
the pawn so black needs to stop it with
Bishop to e7 but there comes fish up to
F true deflecting the whole piece and
after Bishop captures f2 and promoting
the Queen this is a technical winning
and game so now you understand how white
can Queen his spawn so let's compare
this scenario with our original let me
roll back again one more time so we know
here there
that Bishop to g5 King to be Phi Bishop
to e3
King to a6 if this bishop is not on h2
then we can create a winning position so
it's obvious that here what has to waste
one move in order to create our position
once again I like you to think about
whatever we have seen so far and find
out a winning strategic plan well there
are few ways you can do it over here but
I think the straightforward way is
Bishop to c5
so now black King cannot move because if
we move to somewhere then Bishop will go
to the a7 and white is winning so that
means black has to move the bishop and
it doesn't matter whether this Bishop
goes let's say fish up to g3 and now
comes the whole idea behind this vesting
one Bishop to e7 so now White has a very
simple idea that is he wants to play
Bishop to d8 and Bishop to c7 and
promoting the Queen so once again black
responds his force black has to stop it
King to be Phi Bishop to d8 and now King
to c6 stopping that plan but there's a
major difference from the original
position that is now this Bishop on this
g3 square and that creates our winning
sequence did you remember it well yup
Bishop to h4 challenging the Bishop
Bishop to f4 Bishop to f2 reaching to
the a7 square and after King to b5
Bishop to e7 King to a6 fish up to b8
clearing the diagonals and after Bishop
to e3 fish up to g3 and Bishop to e7 we
have the winning move Bishop to have
true which creates this technical
winning and gain well I hope
enjoy and learn my first episode of
advanced chess in game tutorials feel
free to like subscribe and comment on
this video and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care
you